[Musik]
das jahr geht zu ende
sie sind immer noch da die
selbsternannten querdenker trotz zweiter
welle trotz steigender todeszahlen nicht
der protest nicht verpufft
und noch immer oder mehr denn je rätselt
die mehrheit der deutschen was genau
treibt diese menschen hier an
sind das alles nazis spinne revidierten
oder machen wir es uns damit nicht auch
viel zu einfach rein in die schublade
lag damit die meisten hier haben kein
vertrauen mehr in die moderne
wissenschaft in die politik in uns
medien will nicht lügen wir sind keine
nazis
woher kommt das
wie kann es sein dass sie einem
youtube-video mehr glauben als einer
seriösen studien
und was heißt das für uns als
gesellschaft
das wollte ich wissen
was mir dabei wichtig war ich wollte mit
dem selbst ernannten querdenkern in ein
gespräch kommen ein echtes gespräch
abseits der demos in ruhe mit ihnen
reden
also habe ich versucht kontakte zu
knüpfen zugegeben das war nicht immer
einfach aber manche waren bereit nicht
zu sich einzuladen
ich glaube sie sind wirklich dass eine
diktatur errichtet werden soll
bei uns und ich wollte wissen gibt es
einen querdenker effekt kann uns corona
spalten über die sozialen medien habe
ich einen aufruf gestartet
viele der nachrichten die mich erreicht
haben zeigen wie tief die gräben hier
und da schon sind welches bereits klima
entstanden ist
querdenker nazis klimaleugner noch nie
war es so einfach die freundesliste zu
minimieren kohona ist ein charaktertest
und einige menschen haben ihn bisher
nicht bestanden
[Musik]
aus all diesen ganz verschiedenen
stellen ist dieser film entstand
[Musik]
und
[Applaus]
konstanz anfang oktober für zwei tage
versammeln sich die querdenker am
bodensee einige tausend sind gekommen
es ist wie ein großer jahrmarkt ein fest
für empörte allerhand
[Musik]
sein
was bringt
die freiheit ruft das war ja die fühle
mich eingeschränkt was macht sie so
sicher dass man durch eine impfung den
körper schädigt das ist mein klarem
menschenverstand es ist mein kinder ist
dass ich mein tiefes gefühlt aber
intuition die hat keiner mehr ist ja
nicht wissen dass irgendjemand dass es
ein buch erklärt das ist schon so nahe
kommt hat der weiß jeder von uns hat der
wiesn rainer vertraut auf sein wissen es
gibt nicht den querdenker man muss sich
quer denken eher wie eine protesten
plattform vorstellen auf der sich ganz
unterschiedliche positionen finden
natürlich gibt es hier auch spinner und
auch rechte aus diesem bollerwagen
heraus wird das kompakte magazin
verkauft dass der verfassungsschutz als
rechtsextrem verdachtsfall listet
das q ist eine mehr oder weniger
versteckte anspielung auf yuan eine
verschwörungstheorie die in der korona
krise weltweit anhänger gewinnt glauben
sie dann an dieser theorie
ich glaube dass wir mittel eine wandels
sind ob sie jetzt alleine mit co oder
mit koan und zusammenhängt oder erklärt
werden kann das würde ich jetzt nicht zu
sagen dieser crew behauptet ja dass die
eliten kinder halten und deren blut
trinken hat war nicht dabei ich kann
nichts ausschließen
halten sie das für denkbar ich halte
grundsätzlich alles für denkbar
der kompaktwagen ist teil des konstanz
erklärt erik meijer max niemand scheint
sich daran zu stören
dabei fühlen sich die meisten querdenker
zu unrecht in die rechte ecke gedrängt
im august ändert sich die bisher größte
demonstration gegen die korona politik
mit dem versuch das reichstagsgebäude
zustimmen
[Musik]
ein tabubruch in konstanz sind auch
deshalb einige hundert
gegendemonstranten gekommen
wer mit nazis demonstriert der hat
wirklich nichts kapiert skandieren sie
darüber und hören sich wiederum die quer
denn man kann förmlich dabei zuschauen
wie sich die gräben vertiefen und der
riss geht längst auch quer durch
freundschaften quer durch familien
sollen die rechte ecke geschoben und
meine ich bin alles andere als recht
das ist was du bist querdenker mit den
rechten möchte ich nichts zu tun haben
von wem werdet ihr in die rechte ecke
geschoben
selbst unsere eigenen kinder studieren
doch die wissen dass wir nicht recht
sind aber die auch sagen was macht ihr
mit den chaoten und den rechtsextremen
zusammen und demonstriert seine leute
das sind ganz normale menschen und genau
diese menschen nicht die freaks nicht
die spinne die suche
wer sind die warum sind sie hier warum
trauen sie politik wissenschaft medien
nicht mehr
7 09 13
ich sammle telefonnummern und kontakte
will in ruhe reden abseits der demo
erregung
in den wochen danach führen wir
stundenlange telefonate und mein team
und ich tauchen ein in die welt der
querdenker die meisten wollen nicht vor
die kamera
manche fahrer sind bereitet mitte
november werde ich nach kusterdingen
eingeladen eine gemeinde in der nähe von
tübingen ein kleines bürgerliches idyll
mit historischem ortskern und vielen
einfamilienhäusern
[Musik]
aber auch eine halbe größe vielen dank
für die einladung der verein gern
konzern bleib draußen am schild schon
gesehen bis sie geholt
oder ist es eine maske die erhoffte
ein café oder sehr gerne barbara meine
mutter von drei kindern arbeitet im
rechtsanwaltsbüro ihres mannes
sie hat bisher immer rot oder grün
gewählt ließ seit 30 jahren den spiegel
und ist jetzt plötzlich querdenkerin
wann war der moment wo sie gesagt haben
ich bin mit dieser politik nicht
einverstanden
spätestens beim lockdown ja also alles
anfing hier alles absolut runter zu
fahren und ich mir ausgemalt habe was
passiert dann hinter den türen was
passiert mit den menschen was passiert
in alten mit den alten menschen
meine schwiegermutter ja die und sieht
man sehen will ich meinen sie es 85 ich
glaube nicht dass sie ewig lebt ja also
wie sich zurückzieht und auch
installiert und sie hatten keine angst
um ihre schwiegermutter meinen habe ich
nicht ich meine ich weiß es nicht ich
kann sich vor aussehen aber ich kann
nicht vor allem angst haben nicht
verstecken das ist auf jeden fall mal
eine lebenshaltung die ich schon immer
habe egal in welchem bereich ich bin
wenn ich ohne angst reingehen wenn ich
immer noch sorgen kann ich viel anders
handeln und viel besser durch die
situation durchgehend als wäre ich damit
eine angst reingehen und die angst wird
aufrechterhalten wenn ich die zeitung
morgens auf schlag ich gucke den spiegel
online ich guck sonst vor ein ich denke
nur furchtbar was das hier und das
bestellt sich nicht
dann ging es los gegangen und habe ihnen
alternativen medien um getan habe ich
war übrigens auch noch nicht gekannt ich
habe auch den traditionellen medien
eigentlich immer vertraulich als
kritisch gelesen warum glauben sie
diesen portalen mehr als einer
zeitschrift für dem spiegel
beispielsweise ein melder spiegelt das
immer so dargestellt als ob es wirklich
dramatisch ins schlimm dass wieso greift
man jetzt ausgerechnet bei corona so
stark ein
und bei allen anderen krankheiten nicht
das verstehe ich nicht also im moment
kommen ja jede woche mehr und mehr
menschen auf intensivstationen und wenn
es diese lockdown maßnahme ist nicht
gegeben hätte wer die entwicklung ja
viel steiler verlaufen
ich meine ja es gibt ja fertig die das
hoch reicht ja das hochrechnen genau das
ist genau der punkt des weiteren ein
mathematisches modell draus gemacht der
mensch zählt nichts mehr
es wird der körper komplett abgekoppelt
es geht nur um den körper ja es geht
nicht nur um sehen und geist in der
kommune krise ja es geht nur den körper
so zu schützen von diesen virus
egal mit welchen stoffen egal was erste
auswirkungen hat egal wie weit ich da
eingeschränkt wenn im ganzen würden sie
das ganze anders sehen wenn sie jetzt in
ihrem bekanntenkreis jemanden hätten der
schweren verlauf gehabt hätte vielleicht
auf intensivstationen legen will habe
ich mir auch schon überlegt was wäre
wenn ich jetzt kroner krieg und
schwerkranke und rechtsgrund
langzeitwirkung das würde für mich immer
noch nicht rechtfertigen dass alle
anderen auf diese art und weise damit
maßnahmen eingesperrt oder eingeschränkt
werden
barbara meinl ist anthroposophisch
aufgewachsen und auch wenn sie sich
selbst nicht als strenge anhängerin
dieser lehre versteht die einheit von
körper seele geist die tiefe überzeugung
dass die welt nicht nur
naturwissenschaftlich zu verstehen ist
all das sind kerngedanken der
anthroposophie gerade hier im südwesten
deutschlands ist sie tief in der
gesellschaft verankert in der korona
krise kann dieses denken plötzlich
hochpolitisch werden man muss nicht am
rand der gesellschaft stehen um
querdenker zu werden jeder fünfte der
selbsternannten querdenker hat einer
umfrage zufolge bei der letzten
bundestagswahl die grünen gewählt
ich sage mal was ich nicht verstehe ja
es gibt sehr viele gründe maßnahmen zu
kritisieren für mich man kann es auch
unverhältnismäßig bin ich verstehe nicht
warum diese keule rausgeholt werden also
keule wie wir ja ab in einem totalitären
staat meinungsfreiheit ist eingeschränkt
was ist passiert
das ist ganz einfach passiert sie können
auch ihre meinung über sagen natürlich
kann ich noch sprechen aber es geht
nicht um mich ja es geht auch das was
ich erfahre
es fängt damit an dass man eine andere
meinung hat ja eigentlich sofort den
stempel hat so ja du bist rechts kroner
kritiker korridor idiot und was auch
immer sie dann als co videoteam schon
bezeichnet worden nehrig leute corona ja
nächstes sollte das nicht ich glaube die
krankheit gibt es ja weil sie gerade
gesagt haben das ist dass man dann immer
gleich in seiner ecke gestellt also ich
persönlich
nein nein das hat mir noch keiner so
bestimmt wenn sie jetzt so zurückschauen
die letzten monate wie hat corona wir
leben ihr denken ihr weltbild verändert
also ich denke die welt ist absolut im
umbruch und dann wird nicht mal seinen
vorher ja definitiv
und ich habe jetzt auch gelernt dass es
eben nicht alles so weiter geht wie ich
es mir wünsche ganz viele bereiche
gescheucht kritischer an was ich tue
also mein digitaler konsum ja mein
medienkonsum zum beispiel ich glaube
auch nicht dass alles wieder gut wird
neben leben mit dem impfstoff
[Musik]
es kommt mir vor als wäre barbara meinl
selbst überrascht plötzlich so wenig
einverstanden zu sein der politik so
viel vertrauen verloren zu haben in uns
medien
aber immerhin sie hat sich mit mir einem
journalisten des zdf auf ein gespräch
ein gelassen von anderen die ich in
konstanz kennengelernt habe kamen zum
teil ganz schön schroffe absage
mit verlaub um von einem aus meiner
sicht nur noch vermeintlich seriösen
sender interviewt zu werden und dabei
gefahr zu laufen in meinen aussagen
völlig verdreht und verzehrt zu werden
bin ich mir einfach mal zu schaden
diese sicht auf uns medien begegnet mir
in all meinen gesprächen so heterogen
die querdenker sind darauf können sich
alle einig es wird ja immer nur die
schnitte machen propaganda das ganz
schlicht
doch der widerstand ist da alles kann
spricht ist
fällt nicht mehr die ja schon wieder los
[Applaus]
fake news media als querdenken sommerhit
2020 zudem tausenden mitten in
deutschland im takt mit
in stuttgart bin ich mit jörg sommer
verabredet er ist gründungsdirektor des
berliner instituts für partizipation
einem think tank der sich damit
beschäftigt wie tief die demokratie in
unserer gesellschaft verankert ist jörg
sommer beobachtet den vertrauensverlust
in medien in politik in unserer
demokratischen institutionen seit vielen
jahren in seinen augen sind die
querdenker demonstration symptome eines
problems das wir schon länger haben wir
sind in einer situation wo sag ich mal
die ehe zwischen den politischen
akteuren und teilen sich sagt bewusst
auch kleinen teilen aber durchaus
signifikanten teilen der bevölkerung
eine zerrüttete situation darstellt und
ich glaube dass da auch die politik
gefordert ist mal zu reflektieren wie
man mit so etwas umgehen kann also eine
pauschale beschimpfung als co wie die
roten oder sich nur über bestimmte
plakate aufzuregen oder über die
falschen mit marschieren ist etwas was
nicht weiter hilft sondern was die krise
eher verschärfen würde inwiefern
verschafft na gut es ist ja kein
inhaltliches eingehen auf die
problematik sondern regt sich über die
form auf ja man kann sich auf der guten
auf der richtigen seite wählen weil man
die wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse
akzeptiert oder weil man eine bessere
kinderstube genossen hat als einige
dieser akteure aber das hilft ja nichts
ja also wenn auf dem grabstein der
unserer institution steht sie hatten
recht nutzt das niemand ja
sondern man muss schon ein stück weit
darauf eingehen die frage ist nur
verharmlosen wird diese bewegung damit
nicht auch indem wir sagen man muss nur
mit den menschen reden
es geht nicht um verharmlosung es geht
aber darum einer gewissen demut auch auf
menschen zuzugehen
die aus welchen gründen auch immer nicht
mehr bereit sind die rolle einzunehmen
die unsere gesellschaft für sie
vorgesehen hat wenn wir über
vertrauensverlust dieser menschen
sprechen und dann können wir ja
diagnostizieren
auf diesen vertrauensverlust in unserer
institutionen
dann kann man nicht zwangsläufig davon
ausgehen dass derjenige daran schuld ist
er das vertrauen verloren hat aber wenn
die neben reichs bürgern laufen wenn da
leute behaupten das
infektionsschutzgesetz sei wie das
ermächtigungsgesetz 33 wenn die plakate
hochhalten politiker journalisten
wissenschaftler in sträflingskleidung
abgebildet sind
ja ich bin auch nicht der meinung dass
man mit nazis versuchen muss ein
wertschätzendes gespräch zu führen
das ist keine meinung das ist ein
verbrechen das ist was anderes ja aber
dann kann ich sagen ich diskutiere nicht
mit dir so lange du auf eine demo gehst
auf die auch nazis laufen da bleibt uns
nichts anderes übrig als gewisse
schmerzen zu ertragen nicht zu
akzeptieren aber zunächst mal zu
ertragen aber es ist ja es ist ja eine
kleine minderheit das muss man immer
dazu sagen die große mehrheit hat ja
noch vertrauen in die institutionen
allerdings dann schaut man in die usa
hat fast die hälfte der bevölkerung das
vertrauen oder den glauben auch in die
institutionen verloren muss uns das zu
denken geben
ja das ist nicht ganz so einfach nicht
die zeiten sind vorbei dass alles was
heute passiert zehn jahre später in
deutschland passiert aber das zeigt
natürlich sehr deutlich was was uns
bevorstehen kann wenn wir diese diese
zerrüttung der demokratie nicht wirklich
ganz ernsthaft angehen
[Musik]
jörg sommer empfiehlt mehr gelassenheit
weniger empörung ein gespräch in gang
bringen aushalten
das ist leichter gesagt als getan
und mein gefühl ist das gelingt uns als
gesellschaft gerade so gar nichts kann
uns corona spalten
ich wollte ihre meinung dazu hören und
habe deshalb über die sozialen medien
einen aufruf gestartet
da gibt es keine neutralität
das sind gefährliche spinner die andere
gesundheitlich gefährden
ich sehe keine spaltung maximal drei
prozent der bevölkerung können zwar sehr
laut sein aber werden dadurch nicht eine
mehrheit
[Musik]
die große mehrheit steht hinter den
corona maßnahmen das muss uns immer klar
sein wenn wir über quer denken reden
auch miriam schäfer hatten geschrieben
sie arbeitet als krankenschwester ihr
mann willi hatte coop 19 lag sogar im
krankenhaus
beide können nicht verstehen wie
querdenker tippen
[Musik]
kann uns corona spalten das ist die
frage die mich im moment umtreibt
und sie haben geschrieben so schäfer es
ist mehr als traurig wenn jahrelange
freundschaften zerbrechen wir sehen was
passiert das ist mir passiert ja das ist
und das ist wirklich traurig es ist
bitter aber das war nicht so umgehen
wenn man keinen gemeinsamen nenner mehr
findet und wie war das denn genau
ich wurde heute von einer alten
freundinnen mit irgendwelchen videos von
der youtube universität zugeballert
irgendwelche verschwörungs videos und es
ja sowieso alles hinten und vorne
gelogen und wenn man selbst einer front
steht und hört sich dann so was an denkt
denkt man automatisch
da prallen zwei welten aufeinander wir
haben sie dann reagiert ich hab's halt
gebeten also dass mich einfach aus ihrem
politisch weltanschaulichen verteiler
raus nimmt und dann wurde halt meine
geistige kompetenz infrage gestellt dann
habe ich auf spam gestellt dann habe ich
das reichlich mag nehme ich mag wirklich
nimmer das heißt die freundschaft ist
jetzt durch das ist ja auf jeden fall
mal richtig auf eis gelegt aber müssen
wir nicht so eine diskussion führen also
ich meine das ist jetzt völlig von außen
natürlich einfach zu sagen aber ist es
nicht besser dann im gespräch zu bleiben
natürlich muss man darüber diskutieren
und ich find auch nicht alle maßnahmen
die getroffen wurden
das dass die sinnvoll sind natürlich
muss man hinterfragen da darf man auch
diskutieren
aber das alles als erfindung abzutun als
verschwörung bill gates am besten noch
dafür verantwortlich dass unser fahrer
da wird einfach auf ich war in den
letzten wochen auf einigen
demonstrationen der selbsternannten
querdenker
was denken sie wenn sie die bilder sehen
es ist die erste große demo im fernsehen
gesehen hat das hat bei mir wirklich
nicht angelegt das hat mich so
runtergezogen warum weil ist corona
selbst erlebt habe und weil ich weiß
welche folgen es hat
es kriegt sogar zustimmen ich habe das
ganze durch erlebt und habe selbst so
viele monate danach immer noch meine
probleme und wenn ich dann sehe dass so
viele leute auf einem fleck zum einen
das leugnen und dann keinen abstand
gehalten wird da fehlt mir das
verständnis einfach dafür demonstrieren
ja aber dann nach regeln und die heißen
einfach abstand und maske für mich ist
eine maske nicht nur ein stück stoff für
mich ist eine maske auch respekt
gegenüber den mitmenschen was ärgert sie
beide mit ihrer geschichte sie sind
krankenschwester sie hatten kurve etwas
ärgert sie denn am meisten dass es
überhaupt nicht wahrgenommen wird wenn
menschen sagen ich lasse mir meine
freiheit nicht nehmen weil sie sich
einfach wenn in der öffentlichkeit ein
festklopfen vor die nase binden sollen
die es einfach nicht verstehen dass sie
das machen um andere zu schützen vor den
kannte sie selbst vielleicht verbreiten
wo ist bitte schön das problem die maske
schadet doch niemand was soll das was
soll das
im herbst steigen die infektionszahlen
drastisch an
doch der querdenken protest geht weiter
[Musik]
für den siebten november ist eine große
demonstration in leipzig angekündigt
ort und datum sind bewusst gewählt
querdenken inszeniert sich als erbe der
friedlichen revolution von 1989
[Musik]
ich gehe nicht allein auf diese dinge in
konstanz habe ich einen querdenker
kennengelernt der hier in leipzig lebt
er hat mich eingeladen ihn zu begleiten
haben sie lange überlegen müssen habe
ich mich noch mal treffen
dann haben wir dort hinten eigene hühner
der rasse da ist ja wirklich was ganz
tolles rainer koschorz gebürtiger
leipziger freischaffender schauspieler
und kabarettist die maßnahmen treffen
ihn hart fast alle seiner gastspiele
sind weggefallen erlebt aktuell von
seinen ersparnissen 89 war koschorz bei
den montagsdemonstrationen dabei die
situation heute sagt er erinnere ihn an
damals wir wurden jahrelang in der ddr
falsch informiert ja ich gespürt was in
der zeitung stand wie es in der
wirtschaft aussage ich habe selber in
der wirtschaft gelernt und und da haben
wir doch hier stimmt doch was nicht
also da ist man sowieso als gelernter
ddr-bürger so habe ich mal sehr
sensibilisiert für dinge die einfach
nicht realistisch dargestellt werden und
darum geht es einem passieren eindruck
haben sie heute wieder absolut absolut
die gleichgeschaltete medien damals in
der ddr vergleichen sie mit der dem
zustand heute in unserer demokratie
ich muss jetzt aufpassen was ich sage
aber ich kann es mit ja beantworten ja
an vielen stellen ja aber es wird doch
zum beispiel kritisch auseinandergesetzt
mit der regierungslinie beispiel
beherbergungs verbote da wurde doch ganz
viel kritik geübt auch in den zeitungen
und es werden doch auch zahlen
hinterfragt und es werden maßnahmen
hinterfragt ja ist jetzt angemessen ist
ob schulschließungen sein mussten ob das
richtig war die friseure zu machen usw
da wird doch kritik geübt ich verstehe
nicht ganz was ihnen fehlt wenn man die
leute uns das volk wie auch immer tage
lang täglich ob in der leipziger
volkszeitung oder im fernsehen jeden tag
sagt sohn zu viele neue infizierte dass
das ist doch manipulation ohne ende
das bleibt er in den köpfen hängen warum
ist die situation derweil nicht mehr
unterschieden wird was sind denn
infiziert bitteschön
die krankenhäuser sind nicht überfüllt
und und die kollateralschäden sind
mittlerweile schon jetzt schon höher als
die wirklichen ich sag mal sterbefällen
ganz ehrlich was passiert denn ich sage
ich sag's mal ganz brutal was den 10.000
tote innerhalb von einem dreivierteljahr
ich glaube wir sind jetzt bei 10.000
worden und da machen wir doch nicht von
einer pandemie sprecher aber wie viele
tote hätten wir wenn es keine maßnahmen
gegeben hätte mit sicherheit auch nicht
mehr
bestes beispiel das wird ja es wird es
wird mit mit mit der angst gespielt und
wenn ein volk angst hat ist es viel
besser kontrollierbar und das sind die
zeiten der diktatur
glauben sie denn wirklich dass eine
diktatur errichtet werden soll
bei uns
letztendlich ja wir reden noch
mindestens eine stunde weiter und landen
irgendwann auch bei geheimen mächten die
hinter allem stehen bei bill gates und
superreichen lobbyisten
es ist als würden wir verschiedene
sprachen sprechen
rainer koschorz hält mich für einen der
das ganze einfach nicht durchschaut und
ich verstehe nicht wie man ernsthaft an
so was wie eine verschwörung durch bill
gates glauben kann
für viele hier in leipzig kann corona
einfach nicht die zufällige mutation
eines virus sein
es muss jemand dahinter stecken alles
was geschieht geschieht mit absicht die
stimmung auf dem augustusplatz ist von
anfang an eine andere als in konstanz
nein
und die situation eskaliert als die
vielen tausend querdenker ohne maske
wohne abstand über den innenstadtring
ziehen wollen sowie 89
und obwohl die polizei es ihnen
untersagt hat
[Musik]
die grenzen zwischen rechtsextremen
hooligans mitläufern und querdenkern
verschwimmen vor allem ganz vorne am
protestzug mit der kerze in der hand und
wir sind das volk auf den lippen lassen
sich viele querdenker die straße von
rechts quasi freistunden in leipzig hat
der querdenken protest eine neue
dimension erreicht
ich frage nach bei miro dietrich von der
amadeu-antonio-stiftung miro wir waren
in den letzten wochen und monaten auf
sehr vielen demos wer mit sehr sehr
vielen selbsternannten querdenkern
gesprochen und viele sagen dass da jetzt
nazis mit laufend und uns missbrauch in
unsere bewegung missbrauchen als
plattform dafür können wir nichts was
halten sie von diesem argument das finde
ich schon ein bisschen sprach zum
einlaufen nicht nur nazis und
rechtsextreme mit sondern rechtsextreme
personen stehen auch auf der bühne und
es geht ja nicht nur darum dass sich
hier leute drauf setzen sondern wir
sehen auf jeden fall dass die
rechtsradikalen kräfte sich unter diesen
leuten sehr wohl fühlen und wir sehen
das in den chats rechtssysteme dinge
passieren
wer denkt er hat vor kurzem bei
telegramm die kommentarfunktion auch
angeschaltet und es wurde geflutet mit
mordfantasien mit gewaltaufrufen mit
rechtsextremen inhalten dass es dann
wieder abgeschaltet würde wenn man in
einem demokratischen prozess sich
beteiligen will
dann finde ich es notwendig dass man
klar sagt dass man mit
menschenfeindlichen und
demokratiefeindlichen positionen nichts
zu tun haben will
und das nicht nur beim lippenbekenntnis
lässt
wie gehen wir mit all dem um das ist die
königs fragen gerade hat der
baden-württembergische verfassungsschutz
entschieden die bewegung zu beobachten
er sagt aber auch die mehrheit derer die
da mitlaufen ist nicht extremistisch ich
will nicht so tun als hätte ich eine
lösung aber ich bin mir nach meiner
reise sicher wir können uns die
querdenker wir können uns den
vertrauensverlust wer sich da offenbart
nicht weg empören das heißt nicht dass
wir alles akzeptieren
natürlich müssen wir uns gegen
demokratiefeindliche menschenfeindliche
standpunkte wären aber mit ihr seid alle
nazis ihr seid alle kollidierten mit
pauschalisierung gegen gut kommen wir
nicht weiter das spielt er den in die
hände die wirklich hoffen dass uns
corona spaltet
[Musik]